[Music]
hey what's up I'm Kim BHD here so I
really like Twitter okay this comes from
a place of love but when you really like
something you want to see it succeed so
I've been on Twitter for 13 plus years
I've tweeted over 50 000 times don't
judge me but I use several different
Twitter apps I have third party apps on
my phone I've already made a dear
Twitter video this was five years ago
and actually some of the suggestions
that I made in that video including the
ability to edit tweets now has actually
made it to the product which is kind of
amazing but I don't know if you guys
have heard but Twitter they're kind of
going through a lot right now so Elon
Musk has actually bought Twitter and
taken over leadership very quickly and a
lot of pretty drastic changes are being
made very quickly reorganizing the whole
company firing people unfiring people
tons of new feature suggestions are on
the table honestly it feels like
anything is on the table so from the
outside looking in it just looks like
complete chaos even if you're on Twitter
it's chaos but I just I want it to work
like I want Twitter to be good I I don't
know I'm one of those sickos that
actually enjoys spending time on Twitter
sometimes and maybe it's kind of hard to
explain why but Twitter feels like it's
a pretty unique social media platform
it's an it's a unique experience because
it actually makes everyone feel
reachable like it actually has a pretty
small user base as far as daily active
users Facebook has literally 10 times
the amount of active users Twitter
literally has less daily active users
than Snapchat right now but it does feel
like it has an outsized impact relative
to that number of people like there are
a ton of interesting people
personalities athletes politicians
celebrities musicians artists all over
Twitter and it's just like it feels like
if you could just reach out to any one
of them they might see it and reply back
it just happens all the time so anyway
I'm rooting for Twitter to do well but
with all the chaos going on right now
there's most people do not have that
level of confidence in them at all now a
few days ago I tweeted that YouTube is
in fact still the only true s-tier
social media platform to which Elon
immediately replied for now so you know
what I'm just going to take you at face
value here I'm going to assume and
believe that you actually want Twitter
to be an A plus amazing great social
media platform
so I'm just gonna tell you what I think
Twitter should do to actually achieve
that and this is just coming from my
years of experience on social media Elon
currently follows me on Twitter maybe
he'll see this maybe I can actually make
this a useful video now to be clear I
don't think Twitter becomes an s-tier
social media platform by just aping
YouTube or by you know becoming a direct
YouTube competitor it should still be
its own thing
but as imperfect as it is there's a lot
of things that YouTube does really well
and there's a reason I put it as s tier
and there's a reason the same reason
that a lot of people who blow up on a
different social media platform from
Vine to tick tock to Instagram to
Twitter nine times out of ten their next
move is to try to convert as much of
that as possible to a YouTube channel so
here's a little diagram I made this is
what I'll call The Virtuous cycle of the
YouTube Creator ecosystem it's
oversimplified but obviously many
creators on YouTube use outside tools
but the basic premise is there's a lot
of creators on YouTube and those
creators are making content contributing
to the world's largest online video
library YouTube builds monetization
Tools around those videos which in turn
gets creators paid and happy which gets
them making more content etc etc it just
keeps flowing in a circle now I don't
know exactly how much Elon knows about
YouTube monetization specific typically
are the tools that they've built I'm
again just going to go by face value
here but it's also a legitimately hard
business question If you're trying to
build something like that cycle
where do you jump in like Twitter
doesn't necessarily have YouTube style
massive library of content
but what it does have is a lot of really
interesting high profile creative users
so dear Twitter a suite of evolving
Creator tools would make a massive
difference to the entire website so over
the years YouTube has added things from
all over the place there's the YouTube
Partner program so our advertisers pay
for spots alongside YouTube videos and
YouTube shares 55 of that ad Revenue
with the uploader of the video they also
recently announced monetized shorts even
more Revenue sharing in the shorts feed
starting next year they also have super
thanks which puts a donation button
under a video that makes your comment
distinct and colorful and creators
receive 70 of that donated money they
also have super chats and super stickers
during live streams so viewers can pay
to have their chats highlighted creators
also keep 70 of that money and there's
Channel memberships where you can offer
exclusive content to a smaller group of
paid subscribers or members and the
Creator again get 70 percent of that
money now Twitter actually has some of
this stuff already I think basically
super follows are like the equivalent of
Channel memberships and Twitter actually
beats the percentage by a mile Twitter
will give 97 of the revenue of a paid
follower to that Creator on Twitter up
to 50 Grand and then it's 80 after that
that's still really good but they really
could use more of these things like just
how YouTube has copied a lot of these
features from other platforms Twitter
should also feel free to adapt a lot of
these things for its own platform like I
keep thinking back to remembering like
Periscope and live streaming when that
was happening a lot more often that was
really solid and that should have been
more easily monetized and while you can
upload videos to twitter ads and revenue
sharing aren't really a thing for the
masses but they totally could be I think
they should be imagine you're just a
random user who's making videos putting
them on Twitter and by chance one of
them just pops off and just gets a ton
of exposure or gets retweeted by a bunch
of people and suddenly that's an nice
chunk of change in your pocket that
would be pretty incredible and that also
incentivizes more uploads of high
quality videos to twitter also I saw
Elon respond to our boy Quinn on Twitter
who mentioned that the YouTube Partner
program pays creators 55 and Elon said
they can beat that percentage and that
sounds great I believe you you've
already beat some other percentages from
them but if nobody really advertises on
your platform then the percentage
doesn't really matter does it so that's
where we should just get right into
talking about it relying on advertisers
versus subscriptions so as you've
probably noticed by now uh the internet
runs on ads
it just does like social media platforms
revenues generated by advertisers major
websites and blogs and things that you
read they run on ads like all these big
websites and major content places they
get their revenue from advertising and
as whatever you think about ads like
obviously they're annoying sometimes but
it just it's what makes the world turn
in online media it's just true now these
companies are also smart these these
social media companies especially are
smart because they're trying to
introduce more subscription services so
that they can reduce their Reliance on
ads if you have more subscription
services that people actually pay for
that's recurring Revenue that's
guaranteed every month instead of having
to rely on the finicky ad buyer market
so Snapchat made Snapchat Plus which is
a four dollar a month subscription for
some extra custom stories and post
settings and notification features meta
launched Instagram subscriptions where
creators can charge up to 100 bucks a
month for exclusive content including
stories we even have an MKBHD Discord
Channel which is mostly free but now
also has premium memberships with extra
channels and the thing that all of these
successful subscription Services have in
common is adding value or at least
adding perceived value for the person
paying but here's the thing
ads still run the internet like as
successful as some of these subscription
models have been ads are still where the
revenue is at here uh here's an example
YouTube has 2.6 billion monthly active
users it's gigantic right how many of
them do you think pay for YouTube
premium
go ahead yes 2.6 billion total so you
get it's 12 bucks a month you get
background play you get no ads you get
the ability to download stuff for
offline how many people you think
about 20 million people pay for YouTube
premium so that's good money sure but
that's you know about 10 of the 28
billion dollars they made in that
calendar year so yeah YouTube still runs
on ads even Netflix the like grandfather
of subscription models for Content they
also just recently added in ads here
like it's just it feels like 10 is like
the magic number of how much revenue you
can make with subscriptions if it's a
great subscription service but you just
make the rest of your money with ads but
Twitter you know they really really want
to reduce the Reliance on advertisers if
they want to completely avoid any
potential adpocalypse if they want
Twitter to be this free speech Haven
that is every advertiser's worst
nightmare if they really want to turn
the corner on Subscription Service
Revenue then they have to make a really
good Subscription Service they have to
make it full of features that people
actually want to pay for you know what I
always think back to
people pay 30 a month for LinkedIn
premium
thirty dollars a month that's that's a
lot of money but that's because they
offer real features that people actually
get value from so fun fact many years
ago I tweeted uh just off the top of my
head a random subscription idea that I
had for YouTube this isn't like 2016 and
the brilliant name I came up with was
YouTube blue and I basically just wanted
it to offer faster priority processing
for extremely large uploaded files like
I would I would totally pay every month
as an uploader for priority processing
because that's a value to me someone who
creates content for YouTube but now many
years later we have this thing called
Twitter blue great oh it's a
subscription service what a coincidence
beautiful we should fill it with things
that people actually want to pay for so
my main request Twitter
is
putting actual time and effort into
thinking of and developing
features for Twitter blue that are
actually good and worth extra dollars
and I think that focusing on the Creator
class and power users of Twitter can
probably be a really good guidance point
for those things so unfortunately the
first year of Twitter blue kind of
sucked because most of the features
weren't really compelling for very many
people like you could undo tweets which
was kind of stupid but you could also
upload longer videos that were up to
1080p now you can actually edit tweets
for real which is really cool and it's
getting better but think back to all of
those Creator tools that we just
mentioned earlier and those types of
things would be worth way more than
eight bucks a month to many people
especially people just like me who
create a lot of content and things that
can just go on Twitter because it
unlocks monetization for all types of
content and I would pay for itself very
quickly I guess what I'm trying to say
is having a little verified human check
mark next to your name doesn't feel like
something that will be worth eight
dollars to most people especially
because the benefit is to everyone else
on the platform and not the person
paying so strikes me as something that
should probably just be free but this
has been really interesting to watch
right now there are 400 000 verified
users on Twitter so judging from elon's
tweets because that's kind of all we
have to go by being verified will be one
of the features looped into Twitter blue
so let's say a hundred percent of them
pay eight bucks a month to keep their
badge that would be 77 million dollars
per year
which sounds like a lot but again just
to refresh your memory Twitter made
about five billion dollars of Revenue
last year 92 percent of it was from
advertising and so this would just be a
drop in the bucket but it sounds like
elon's plan is to have everyone pay you
know every every real human on Twitter
connect a credit card pay eight bucks a
month that's their ID and then just keep
using Twitter like normal which
kind of violates my rule number one of
the internet which is you probably can't
charge money for something that was
previously free I don't think most
people are going to want to do that I
really think that new value added to
Twitter that people would choose to pay
for like better features higher quality
media I think that's the way there's a
whole thread I'll link below of like
random ideas someone just came up with
and did mock-ups for and some of them
are actually really interesting and I
could see Twitter power users loving
some of that stuff but like the eight
bucks a month for a verified human
profile it was like guaranteed a
negative reaction just because it's new
money for something that's not new so in
summary I think Twitter blue right now
is a pretty weak attempt at getting like
as many people as possible to pay for
Twitter
and I don't think there is any amount of
cool features you could add to get most
normal people to pay for Twitter what I
do think they should focus on is a
smaller higher conversion group of power
users and creators
and then you will need Advertiser
Revenue to get into that virtuous cycle
so I'll just leave you with this chart
again this is what I think success can
look like for Twitter like Twitter
Twitter is what it is because of the
people on Twitter as with any other
social media platform like that's just a
fact so I think that's where you jump
into this cycle by making things
features and tools that those people
genuinely want and then crafting the
rest of the rules and features around
the behavior that you want
works every time like if posting this 10
minute video on Twitter would cost me
eight bucks a month where posting this
video on YouTube would actually make me
money then it's kind of a no-brainer I'm
posting it on YouTube and then I'll put
a link on Twitter because that's what
the rules and the features incentivize
so yeah that's just my two cents and hey
maybe maybe elon's serious about not
really caring about the economics of
Twitter at all in which case that would
actually be totally cool but the 44
billion dollars aren't going to pay
itself so there you have it thanks for
watching I'm rooting for your Twitter
catch you in the next one peace
[Music]